how's my man Oh what they play huh  I really hope you're happy there you  know mister you okay to bring you back  they've never managed connected  computers of the archive  I waited a long time and then I saw  something  [Music]  we had a visit from the archive company  the subject is Elmo Julie Earth's 10  times so far two years eight months four  days she's not ready to go yet  of course they think your robots might  be based around their technology we are  obliged to act with force if necessary  you made another like me I'm not  replacing it but you did it  what was she like  I went today this is hell  can you hear me  do not let her outside under any  circumstances  I have to try to get her back I am  shutting you down in a jiffy do they  want  they want you  you  you